I want to start my lecture today.
Looking back to that handout I
gave you but didn't give you a, uh,
a discussion of a couple of days ago.
Um,
from that essay,
good readers and good writers that I
quoted at the very beginning of class. Uh,
this term,
if you took the time to read that,
what you saw is novakof meditating
on how reader and writers meat.
Yeah.
And so I just want to read
to you a little bit, uh,
from that, if you still
have it, you can get it out.
The real writer,
the fellow who sends
planets spinning and models,
Amanda Sleep and eagerly
tampers with the sleepers rib,
that kind of author has no
given values at his disposal.
He must create them himself.
The Art of writing is a very few
tile business. If it does not imply,
first of all, the art of seeing the
world as the potentiality of fiction.
The material of this world may be
real enough as far as reality goes.
But it does not exist at all as
an excepted entirety. It is chaos.
And to this chaos,
the author says,
go allowing the world
to flicker and to fuse.
It is now recombined and it's very,
Adam's not merely in it's
visible and superficial parts.
The writer is the first man to map
it and to name the natural objects it
contains.
Those berries are edible.
That speckled creature that bolted
across my path might be tamed.
That lake between those trees will be
called Lake Opal or more artistically
dishwater lake.
That mist is a mountain and that mountain
must be conquered up a track list.
Slope climbs the master artist
and at the top on a windy ridge,
whom do you think he meets?
The panting and happy reader and they
spontaneously embrace and are linked
forever if the book lasts forever.
So this is Nabar coughs,
beautiful advocation of how writer and
reader meet at the summit of this misty
mountain of the imagination.
But I've been suggesting to you over the
course of the lecture so far this term
that this is for many books,
a totally idealized sense
of how reader encounters it.
And no book demonstrates that in quite
the same way on our syllabus as Lolita
itself.
Um,
it's true that black boy
was censored even after it,
it was published in its abbreviated form,
um,
in the 80s. It was censored
from high school libraries,
but Lolita was censored at the very
start in a different way and completely,
um,
if you read,
as I asked you to do the essay at
the back on a book and titled Lolita,
you'll see as Novakof describes,
he circulated it to American publishers,
four of them,
and it was turned down by everybody
finally published in France by the Olympia
press, which had also publish to other
controversial books like naked lunch.
Um,
and Lady Chatterley's lover,
MMM Nabar
cough cannot meet his reader in on the
misty mountain because somebody has to
agree to publish this book first.
It has to exist in the world
before that reader can meet it.
And the very fact of censorship.
So the book was published
by the Olympia pressed,
and then it was banned
in France and in Britain.
It was imported into the United States.
And several years later, uh, uh,
an American publication was made and
it rocketed to the bestseller lists.
So it was a very popular book in the u
s but it did have this history of being
banned in Europe and it was
certainly controversial here.
Therefore, the mark of censorship
is actually still on this book.
The essay that you read was produced
at the behest of his French publisher.
They wanted him to write something that
would make people feel better about the
book that would give some account of
its origin and give some defense for its
publication and its content.
And so we have it bound
with the book always now.
And so in a way you can say that
although it's Nabar coughs voice and it's
adding to the novel,
nothing was taken away from the novel
in the way that half of black boy was
removed before it was published.
It's still deformed in a certain way
or influenced by the history of that
censorship.
Now
I think it's worth thinking
about what he says in that essay.
And I'm especially interested in,
um,
this passage on three 13
about the genre fiction of,
of pornography.
So this is three 13,
if you'll turn to it.
Hmm.
In modern type times, the
term pornography, keynotes,
mediocrity, commercialism,
and certain strict rules of narration,
obscenity must be mated with banality
because every kind of aesthetic enjoyment
has to be entirely replaced
by simple sexual stimulation,
which demands the traditional word for
direct action upon the old rigid rules
must be followed by the pornographer in
order to have his patient feel the same
security of satisfaction as,
for example,
fans of detective stories feel
stories where if you do not watch out,
the real murderer may turn out to be to
the fans discussed artistic originality,
who for instance, would want a detective
story without a single dialogue in it.
Thus,
in pornographic novels,
action has to be limited to
the copulation of cliches.
Artistic originality turns out to be
the murderer to the fans discussed.
Artistic originality here is likened
to the murderer of convention.
It's originality that destroys convention.
And here it's given that free
saw of being a criminal to,
he's suggesting the criminality
of real artistic innovation.
And by doing that,
by using that language to
describe artistic originality,
he allies artistic originality
with the figure of Humbert.
So there's,
there's,
there are multiple ways at multiple levels
that Novakof is defending his work in
this. Afterward, he, for one
thing, he insults the publishers.
He suggested that they didn't finish
the manuscript because when his,
his manuscript turned out not to
be pornographic genre fiction,
they stopped reading because that's
what they wanted. And they said,
this is a terrible,
put it down.
So he insults the people who turned
down the book in the United States.
He ally's originality with criminality
and he suggests that it is the,
but now attention to convention that
is in fact what needs to be censored,
what needs to be done away with.
Yeah.
He also gives us few notice his little
secret map of Lolita or so it seems as
it's presented to us,
his secret map of the scenes that
delight him in his own novel.
And this is on three 16
okay.
I find it Lolita to be
a delightful presence.
Now that it quietly hangs about
the house like a summer day,
which one knows to be bright
behind the haze there,
he's playing with the name
Hayes and when I lost,
think of Lolita.
I off out seem always to pick out for
special delectation such images as Mr Tech
Sovich or that list of Ramsdale school
or Charlotte seeing waterproof or Lolita
in slow motion advancing towards Humberto
gifts or the pictures decorating.
The stylized Garret of
Gastrin will go down,
or the Kas Been Barber who cost me a
month of work or Lolita playing tennis or
the hospital at Elphinstone or Pale
pregnant beloved irretrievable Dolly
Schiller dying in gray star,
the capital town of the book
or the tinkling sounds of
the valley town coming up.
The mountain trail on which I caught
the first known female of listed as sub
love sub livens. My, my
Latin is bad [inaudible].
These are the nerves of the novel.
These are the secret points.
The subliminal coordinates by
means of which the book is plotted.
Although I realize very clearly that these
and other scenes will be skimmed over
and not noticed.
We're never even reached by those
who begin reading the book under the
impression that is something along the
lines of memoirs of a woman of pleasure.
He says these are the scenes and I
want you to keep those scenes in mind.
Some of them we've already talked about,
Andrew talked about the class list and
gave you some ways of understanding those
pictures in Gusto Guitars, um, apartment.
So we've talked about those today.
I'm going to pick up on some of those
other scenes that he mentions as his
secret points of delight in the novel.
What kind of novel do we see
if we attend to those scenes?
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take that essay,
the product of censorship,
the response to censorship,
and I'm going to use it to
read back into the novel.
And I want to work with you to see what
we can see if we use those scenes as our
points of reference.
And so our task today will be to think
about that second road trip in the novel.
So this was your reading for today to
begin at that second road trip that Lolita
initiates and think about what happens
to the novel from there to the end.
Now the most conspicuous things that
happen are an increase in the violence of
the novel. He hits her, he pushes her,
he rapes her repeatedly.
We see more of those scenes in
the second half of the novel.
His style becomes more manic.
It gets even funnier.
There are many passages of outright
comedy in this second half,
especially the shooting of quilty,
um,
this sort of parody of the
climax of a crime movie.
So there are all kinds of
flourishes in the style,
and Humbert presents himself as
more and more of a hapless madman.
You can see it in his perceptions.
You can see it in his language.
You can see it in the behavior.
He reports as when he, uh,
he vomits at the resort in Colorado when
he thinks that Lolita has gone away.
And then he sees her playing
with the dog and he thinks, Oh,
if only she would play with me. She's
playing with a damn dog and then he, he,
he's sickened by this idea.
You see more of that kind
of physical deterioration.
He drinks more so he's
getting very desperate.
Lowly on the other hand becomes more
calculating and it's this that I want to
focus in on today.
What becomes of Lolita
in this second part,
and I want to suggest if we turn to page
two of seven in the beginning of that
trip,
I want to suggest that in the second
half Lolita takes on the role of the
artist.
Okay.
If you'll recall.
The two of them have a fight over her
participation in the play because he
suspects her of deceiving him somehow
either with boys or somehow with someone
associated with the play.
He doesn't quite suspect the truth yet
that she has met a quilty through that
play.
So they have this big fight.
It's raining.
She rides her bicycle way into the rain.
When the neighbor calls to complain
about they're yelling at each other.
So this is on two oh six two oh seven.
Okay.
In front of the first drug
store I saw with what?
Melody of Relief Lolita's
fair bicycle waiting for her.
I pushed instead of pulling, pulled,
pushed, pulled and entered. Okay.
There he is struggling with the door.
There's that physical comedy and I'll
suggest to you that in that sentence,
the pushing and pulling, you're seeing
part of Nabar coughs, verbal play.
It's not just sort of physical
comedy translated into prose,
but there are a host of other moments
in the novel we're pushing in polling
figure darkly.
In one of the rape scenes,
he pushes her into her room.
Um,
less darkly at the drugstore,
the soda jerk pulling on
the Levers of the dispenser.
Look out some 10 paces away.
Lolita threw a glass of a telephone booth.
Membranous God's still with us, cupping
the to confidentially hunched over it,
slit her on at me,
turned away with her treasure heartedly
hang up and walked out with a flourish.
So here now we moved from Humberto
verbal flourish to Lolita's physical one
tried to reach you at home. She said
brightly. A great decision. Has been made,
but first,
buy me a drink dead.
She watched the listless Pale
Fountain girl put in the ice,
pour in the coke ad the Cherry Syrup, and
my heart was bursting with love. Ache.
That childish wrist. My lovely child.
You have a lovely child, Mr Humbert.
We always admire her as she passes by Mr
Pim watches pip us suck the concoction
she [inaudible] admitted. Hey Luca
or moan does, who beamed Dubois.
And in the meantime,
the rain had become a voluptuous shower.
So here's his verbal ecstasy
as he watches her look,
she said as she rode the bike beside me,
one foot scraping the darkly glistening
sidewalk. Look, I've decided something.
I want to leave school. I hate
that school. I hate the play.
I really do never go back. Find another
leave at once. Go for a long trip again.
But this time we'll go wherever I want,
won't we?
I nodded my Lolita.
I choose sales tone do.
She said Womblay wobbling
a little beside me.
Used French only when she was
a very good little girl. Okay,
I'll tell him to do now.
How Popup Lenore or you'll get soaked.
A storm of sobs was filling my chest.
She bared her teeth and after her
adorable schoolgirl fashioned,
lean forward and a way she sped my bird,
Miss Lester's finally groomed hand,
held a porch door open for a
waddling old dog keep hunting salt.
Tom Lowe was waiting for me
near the ghostly birch tree.
I'm drenched.
She declared at the top of her voice.
Are you glad to hell with the play?
See what I mean,
and invisible hags clause slammed down
and upper floor window in our hallway
ablaze with welcoming lights.
My Lolita peeled off her sweater,
shook her jammed hair stretched
towards me to bear arms,
raised one knee,
carry me upstairs please.
I feel sort of romantic tonight.
She's juicing him in this scene,
so the flourish passes from his prose.
It's not gone from his prose,
but in this scene very clearly it passes
from his prose into her acting and
Humbert reflects that her work in
the play has trained her into certain
affectations.
Unfortunately for him,
he doesn't exactly spot this one.
She now is using the cliches of romance
to seduce him into following her map for
their second journey.
Starting out on this second journey by
calling forth all his mad love for her so
that he will be in a sense blinded
by that and not see her machinations.
You see it again on two oh
nine little later in this, uh,
in this scene.
His suspicion is,
is aroused when a car pulls up next to
them as they're heading out of town.
It's Dusa gold driving up next to them
and he's asking who, who
was it exactly that, uh,
had been impressed by Lolita's acting,
um,
and Lolita takes him to mean who was
the person in the car next to them,
not who was the person that the
person in the car was referring to.
I was not referring to her. Who exactly
concocted that play. Oh yes, of course.
Some old woman, Claire something. I guess
there was quite crowd of them there.
So she complimented,
you complimented my eye.
She kissed me on my pure brow and my
darling emitted that new Yelp of Merryman,
which perhaps in connection with her
theatrical mannerisms she had lately begun
to effect.
Okay,
and I just want to skip down to
the bottom of that paragraph.
He gives her a kind of warning, which I'm
going to talk about in a little while,
but at the very end he says,
mmm,
the tour of your thigh, you know, should
not exceed 17 and a half inches. She,
he's warning her not to grow
up essentially more. Might
be fatal. I was kidding.
Of course, we are now setting out
on a long happy journey. I remember,
and then look at the paragraph
break there. I remember as a child,
now this is not in quotes.
I remember as a child in Europe gloating
over a map of North America that have
had Appalachian Mountains bolding,
run boldly running from Alabama up to
new Brunswick so that the whole region
they spend Tennessee, the
Virginia's Pennsylvania, New
York, Vermont, New Hampshire,
and Maine appeared to my imagination as
a gigantic Switzerland or even to bet
all mountain glorious
diamond peak upon peak.
This is the realm of that mountain of
imagination that I was showing you in the,
um, passage from good
readers and good writers.
This is hummingbirds meditation on looking
at a map and seeing a range in which
imagination can have pure play.
Now, as it turns out, and you,
if you keep reading there,
he's disappointed to find
what the Appalachian mountains
actually look like in
the United States. He finds
them much less romantic, uh,
kind of garbage dump,
a very seedy stretch of the world.
Um,
but what I wanted to note is how that
chapter break brings us from Lolita's
first efforts at motivating
the romantic cliches.
Her first efforts immediately pay off in
transporting him into that mountainous
imagination.
This is how we know that she's got him.
She's got him in the imagination.
He,
she's not just seduced his last full body.
She has him
fully under her power at this point and
it's that chapter break that you can see
demonstrating the fact.
Now I want to look at page two 31 to
32 this is one of those passages that
novakof points out as
being special to him.
This is Lolita playing tennis
actually.
So two 31
okay,
my Lolita,
this is near the bottom of the page.
How to way of raising her bent left knee
at the ample and springy start of the
service cycle when there would develop
and hang in the sun for a second of vital
web of balance between toed foot,
pristine armpit,
burnished arm and far back flung racket
as she smiled up with gleaming teeth at
the small globe,
suspended so high in the zenith of the
powerful and graceful cosmos she had
created for the express purpose
of falling upon it with a clean,
resounding crack of her golden whip.
It had that serve of her as
beauty directness, youth,
a classical purity of trajectory,
and was despite its spanking pace,
fairly easy to return having as it did
no twist or sting to its long elegant
hop.
Okay.
And then a little further down the page,
she who was so cruel and crafting
everyday life revealed and innocence of
frankness,
a kindness of ball playing that permitted
a second rate but determined player no
matter how uncouth and incompetent
to poke and cut his way to victory.
Yeah.
That pose the pose of tennis service,
the raised foot,
it's the same pose she uses
to seduce him in that scene.
I just read after their fight,
I feel sort of romantic tonight.
She is acting out a
form in the first case,
the form of, of, of romantic fiction,
the heroine who swoons back in this scene,
the form of the game,
the perfect form of tennis.
And he says she did a
perfect imitation of top,
not tennis.
This is on two 31 her for was indeed
an absolutely perfect imitation of
absolutely top notch tennis
without any utilitarian results.
It's perfect tennis but she never
wins and he reflects on two 32
had not something within
her been broken by me,
not that I realized it then she would
have had on top of her perfect form the
will to win and would have
become a real girl champion.
He reads the Non Utilitarian quality of
her form as the evidence of her broken
nature,
but I would like to suggest that it's
precisely that non utilitarian quality
that is the mark of her
wholeness in a certain way.
If aesthetic bliss is what
novakof confesses his,
his ultimate aim for art in the
essay on a book and titled Lolita,
something like that is what Lolita gives
us in her perfect tennis form without
the will to win the frankness,
beauty,
kindness,
lack of deception
and in that sense it is also a
version of play of children's play,
not competitive play,
which is a different kind of thing but
pure play and this gets us back again to
that image of the chest problem that I
was talking about in my first lecture.
The chest problem is not
in the middle of a game.
It's a puzzle,
but it has verts delight,
a kind of solitary quality,
both of the composer and of the
solver of the chest problem.
So it's not in the course
of competitive play.
And although he uses the language of
competition to describe the relationship
between the composer and the solver,
it's not in that sense a competitive game
as chess would be white against black.
This kind of self absorbed autonomous
play of Lolita's tennis form is the kind
of play that children have.
It doesn't have a point.
It's all process and form.
If the threat to the work of art to
the novel is something like convention,
I want to think hard about what the threat
to this kind of play is in the novel.
And I want to suggest that the threat
to this kind of play is parallel to the
threat to children.
The threat to children
in the novel multiplies.
It is not just Lolita who is threatened,
but all sorts of children.
So let's begin with another of those
scenes on to 13 that novakof points out to
us.
The Kas Been Barbara,
why did it take him a month to
come up with the Caspian Barber?
What's going on in this tiny
snippet that's so important?
So here it is in Caz beam.
A very old Barbara gave me
a very mediocre haircut.
He babbled of a baseball playing son of
his and at every exploding spat into my
neck and every now and then wiped his
glasses on my sheet rep or interrupted his
tremulous scissor work to produce
faded newspaper clippings.
And so in attentive was I that it came
as a shock to realize as he pointed to an
easel photograph among the ancient gray
lotions that the mustached young ball
player had been dead
for the last 30 years.
So the barber is speaking about his
son in such a way that he seems alive,
but in fact he's dead.
So here is one dead child playing baseball
or the memory of him playing baseball
is alive with his father.
If you look down at the
very bottom of that page,
you see a young woman far
gone in the family way,
had seated a wrapped baby on a swing and
was rocking it gently while a jealous
boy of two or three was making a nuisance
of himself by trying to push or pull.
There's that wordplay again coming
back to us, the swing board.
He finally succeeded in getting himself
knocked down by it and bawled loudly as
he lays Hoopla supine on the grass while
his mother continued to smile gently at
neither of her present children.
And if you skip over to two 15 this
image comes back of this mother.
All cars had disappeared
except in station wagon.
His pregnant young wife was now getting
into it with her baby and the other more
or less canceled child.
So here are at least three examples of
canceled children and you can use that
phrase I think to characterize Lolita.
She is a canceled child.
Her childhood is stolen
from her by Humbert.
In this scene.
It is the mother's imaginative
preoccupation in a sense that cancels her
children.
And you can ask whether she is preoccupied
with the idea of the new child within
her.
You get that sense of pregnancy being an
inner meaning or an inner significance,
and perhaps it's a figure
for what preoccupies her
for the world of imagination
and possibility. But she has that
kind of distance, distant ETR,
internal smile.
This is the same kind of smile that
Lolita is said to have this beautiful
passage where he Humbert
remembers Lolita's famous smile.
That range is around the room,
but doesn't seem to engage anyone.
It says f her smile is the response
to an internal imagined life.
One that's inaccessible to Humbert.
He says of her,
he does not know what regions
there were in her mind, what dim,
adorable regions there were in
her mind that he would never know,
that he was denied access
to as he raped her.
Okay?
And so children which have this potential
to play are consistently canceled over
and over again.
Okay?
There are other examples.
Um,
on two 23 we find out that Mona
Lolita's friend from the play,
her baby sibling were not told
whether it's boy or girl dies.
And we see it in one of those parents.
Pheta acles two 23 this is Mona's letter.
Yeah.
Now that everything is over school
play the Roy mass mother's confinement.
Our baby alas did not live.
It all seems a long time ago
though practically I still
bear traces of the paint
again,
that parent theoretical a
aligns the death of the child.
We're reminded in this scene of the
death of Lolita's little brother.
I remember Charlotte Hayes speaks in
her letter of a lost son who died at the
age of two.
The bodies of children pile up,
but other things happen to children to
remember when Lolita and Humbert are
partially discovered
having sex in a field by a mother
and her children gathering flowers.
They're described as
carved blue stone children.
Okay.
And think about the name of that town,
Elphinstone of which novakof
again is proud Elphinstone,
a little child of stone,
a small figure of stone
and the Elf like um,
image is something that he
applies to Lolita over and over.
So what you see is children,
Dad,
children turn to stone and this is the
dark side of that fairy tale quality that
we see in other parts of the novel
that's been coming back in our lectures.
These are children turn to stone.
Yeah.
And it suggests if you go back
now to that scene on two oh seven,
two oh eight,
as they set out for the second trip
in the, in the middle of the,
um, in the middle of the page.
Okay.
Actually a little too,
a little above actually,
I was toying with the idea of gently
trickling across the Mexican border.
I was braver now than last year and
they're deciding what to do with my little
concubine who was now 60 inches
tall and weighed 90 pounds.
The threat against Lolita is growing
with her body as she gets bigger,
bigger.
So he becomes murderous towards her.
And this is a lied with his desire in a
sense to crystallize what he has taken
from her.
And here in the middle of
the page a little ways down
my loves striped black and
white cotton frock Jaunty, blue
cap, white sox and Brown moccasins.
We're not quite in keeping with the
large beautifully cut aqua marine on a
silver chain lit,
which jammed her throat a
spring rain gift from me.
He has taken summer rain that the page
before we are told jammed her hair,
shook her gem tear stretched towards
me to bear arms, raised one knee,
her jammed hair takes that
rain and ossified eyes.
It makes it Lapidary,
turns it to stone in the aqua marine
and puts it on a chain lit and the
diminutive let at the end of the
chain doesn't really cover up.
The chain itself doesn't really
mitigate against the confinement he has
perpetrated on Lolita.
She is in chains and just
because it's ornamented,
just because it has the diminutive
doesn't mean that it's not a chain,
it's around her throat.
That vulnerable place.
Yeah.
So if art as play is
something like performance,
something like an embodied art,
the art of the tennis service or
even the art of theater or film,
there's another kind of art
that is gem like hard cold,
equally formal but dead
blue stone children.
Okay.
So this is the other form
that the aesthetic can take.
And I think that Nabar is consistently
concerned about these two valence as of
what the aesthetic can look like.
So if it can look like the gem,
it can last forever as Humbert dreams.
At the very end of the novel he says,
I am thinking of our oxen angels,
the secret of durable pigments,
prophetic sonnets,
the refuge of art.
And this is the only immortality
you and I may share my Lolita.
He thinks of his account as that kind
of enduring stonelike object and it may
give him mortality,
but it traps her there in,
in mortality with him.
He is as I'm as immortal as she
is in the pages of this screed.
Yeah.
And so like the chain lit,
it takes that stonelike distillation
of life turning rain to stone,
turning life to the
representation by your tormentor.
It turns into something
durable that will outlast them.
So the problem with art is in a
sense that it is the immortal,
that's the problem.
If
life is threatened over and over
again in this novel by mortality,
dead children, Lolita, growing
up inevitably painfully
putting her at risk, her body grows.
She can't do anything about it.
That's mortality.
The passage of time,
this difference between the art that's
lapidary and the art that's living is
that the art that's living by very
virtue of being alive can also die.
So this is the problem with
the autonomous work of art.
If your dream as a writer is to make
an autonomous work of art that has,
as we say, in a very colloquial
way, a life of its own.
The book has a life of its own.
We kind of,
we'll say that about a great book or
a great painting it lives on after its
author's death.
We use that metaphor.
But the problem is that there's something
about life that's dependent on the
possibility of its negation.
That's why on Valentine's Day you might
give your lover real flowers rather than
plastic ones.
It's the very potential to
decay that makes them beautiful.
And so the problem here is that novakof
dreams of an art that's living something
like the butterflies that he was so in
chanted with in his life and work outside
of fiction and the butterfly does appear
in just one moment and it's during the
tennis scene as Humbert and Lolita play,
there's one butterfly
that flits between them.
It's a mark of very quality
as artists in that moment.
The Butterfly is the perfect work of art
because it is both a representation and
alive. It has eyes on its
wings. It looks like a leaf.
It is nature in its aesthetic
form as imitation of itself,
life as an imitation of life.
Okay?
Can you make a novel as he says in the
essay that will sprout wings and grow
clause in secret in his mind,
that's an image taken from the
metamorphosis of the butterfly within the
Chrysalis.
He wants his novel to be
like that living butterfly.
But the threat is always that it
will be more like the aqua marine.
And I want to suggest to you that the
aqua marine has an even darker personal
significance to him.
When his family fled Russia,
the only things of value that they brought
with them where some of his mother's
jewels,
these jewels were hidden in a canister
of talcum powder later buried in the yard
under a tree in Europe as they move
from place to place in their exile.
And they were gradually sold off
one by one to fund their life.
Those jewels,
I would suggest to you,
carried with them the sense that they
were the ossified remains of a radiant
Russian life.
And so the image of the jewel is a kind
of dead childhood even for him as a
writer.
So where is newbark off in here?
I think that's one of the
places where Nebach off is
it's novakof meditating on this problem.
I want to read that last,
um,
passage on three Oh eight
that he mentions in the essay.
Actually it starts three Oh seven.
This is Humbert standing on the lip
of our ravine by the side of the road
listening to the sounds of a
small town rising up to him.
And Soon I realized that all these
sounds were of one that no other sounds,
but these came from the streets of the
transparent town with the women at home
and the Mentawais reader. What I heard
was, but the melody of children at play,
nothing but that.
And so limpid was the air that
within this vapor of blended voices,
majestic and my newt remote and magically
near frank and divinely enigmatic one
could hear now and then as if released
an almost inarticulate spurt of vivid
laughter or the crack of a bat
or the clatter of a toy wagon.
But it was all really too far for the
eye to distinguish any movement in the
lightly etched streets.
Ice Did.
Listening to that musical vibration
from my lofty slope to those flashes of
separate cries with a kind of
demure murmur for background.
And then I knew that hope that the
hopelessly poignant thing was not Lolita's
absence from my side,
but the absence of her
voice from that Concord.
This then is my story.
I have reread it.
It has bits of marrow sticking
to it and blood and beautiful,
bright green flies.
The living voice is missing.
What you get instead is the corpse of the
novel with marrow and blood and flies.
Dolly Schiller aptly named of course
for the German romantic philosopher who
advocated play as a mode of the
aesthetic German romanticism of the 19th
century.
Dolly takes on that identity
as the romantic figure and
she dies giving birth to
a girl,
to a baby girl.
She dies in child bed.
Remember I asked you from the preface,
John raised preface to figure out who
Dolly Schiller is, who dies in child bed.
Well,
by now you should know that's Lolita,
so she dies giving birth to a child.
She has taken on the
mantle of romantic artist,
but she dies giving
birth to a live person,
to modes of creativity,
embodied and Lolita in that one act,
and in that name she's giving
birth to a real live thing,
not a creation that is more like stone,
but an actual person.
And so what you see is not
just the paradox of wanting
your work of art to be a
living work of art,
to be personified in that way or made
animate that then exposes it to mortality.
The Woolworth's workers who don't read
it and who think no one in the world ever
reads it,
that kind of risk.
Your book cannot live if it has no reader
to meet it at the top of that mountain,
but Dolly embodies that
other kind of creativeness,
human creativity of the literal
kind giving birth to a child.
I think it's telling that this
kind of creation is a failure.
It cannot succeed in the
confines of this novel.
Nebach off had a way of
making an absence at a point
of his utmost investment.
For instance,
in his autobiography,
he notes the date and the phone call,
the date of,
and the phone call that tells his mother
that his father has been assassinated.
But he doesn't tell you
until many pages later what,
what it was that happened on that date.
He says on whatever the date was,
I think it's March 22nd when my mother
received a phone call and then it just
goes on about something else. It doesn't
tell you what that phone call was.
It was his father's assassination.
Like those absences in
other parts of his writing.
I think this absence,
this failure of any birth,
it marks a sort of vanishing point of art
that art somehow can't quite compete
with the real inventiveness of nature and
of human persons.
He's going to try,
he's going to try to
give us a living prose,
but this is the end against
which it finds itself pressed.
Next week we're going to,
or next time we're turning to a
very different kind of writing, uh,
writing equally preoccupied with its
relationship to the world to life,
but very differently
approaching that problem.
So try to think about that
as you turn to on the road.